the girag an experience where should we
talk about like some conspiracy theories
or something kill himself I don't think
he did nope I think you might not have
maybe maybe this what are the odds that
he did if you had a bet if I was in
Vegas I want to give you odds like hey
the odds he did come on Matt
10% 10% is where I've got it I don't I
don't want to say it's like zero but I
think it's like 10% I think it's low
so would you plunk down a hundred bucks
I'm the one on that that he did kill
himself no yeah probably yeah you'd want
10 do you want more than ten to one that
he did kill himself no I think there's
only a 10% chance he killed right okay
yeah [ __ ] with these numbers here
making it I don't know how you're
however you're converting it to odds
it's falling apart I get it sorry I get
it it doesn't seem going no way though
it does not seem likely no he's crazy
you could still do that did you see the
Ford electric car absolute suicide guard
say they're sweet boots for a broken
system well that's a defense the defense
is just we were incompetent not we
killed him hmm dude who knows
that's jerison weird [ __ ] going on
behind the scenes man what's going on
behind the scene that somebody could
sneak somebody in to kill somebody if
that's what happened what's going oh
this gets an inside person they don't
not gonna sneak somebody and that
person's already inside the cameras are
off bro that's crazy
[ __ ] cameras were cameras were off
whoops sorry
yeah the cameras come on bro I have
cameras at my house they're never
[ __ ] off come on when the cameras are
off - I've heard repeated a few times
but not more recent that there there was
screaming heard from his cell that
someone heard screaming yeah bro we live
in a [ __ ] crazy world yeah that's
dark um I don't know hi okay it's just
that's probably the biggest public
conspiracy theory that most people
believe in do you think most people
believe there was
it was a hit I would say most people I
just read about one last night is there
a poll is there a Pew poll on that oh
she tried to overthrow FDR 1935 in this
general was like the whistle blower fork
because the people that were supposedly
trying to do it we're trying to get him
to be like the face to talk people into
doing it and so he wouldn't talk to
Congress about it his name's like
Smedley Butler I think Smedley Butler
was a Medal of Honor winner and they
called him out and everyone said oh no
that's just a lot as a joke there might
have been some stuff being talked about
in this meeting but we were never gonna
do anything they said they had 500,000
soldiers that were gonna march on DC to
take over and they had some general
they're gonna put a place as addictive
as a book written about us a couple
years ago and this guy Smedley Butler
wrote a book in 1935 called like wars
around Wars a racket yeah Wow Wow so he
knew about all that yeah yeah I just
read about this last night Jesus how do
you know it was a source the book that
it's called um like the time the
conspiracy to overthrow the government
and then it's all it's all about him
it's a really long book that just came
out about like overthrowing FDR Wow hmm
I guess none of this [ __ ] is like new I
feel like I haven't been I'm like I just
turned 38 and I feel like I didn't
really start paying attention to
anything until you know isn't like my
mid-20s or whatever yeah and it's been
you know
yeah Bush was a piece of [ __ ] and then
it kind of seemed on the surface like
Obama was kind of normal but like it and
now obviously we live in crazy town but
but it I think it I think I feel like
it's new and it's not new and this kind
of [ __ ] has just happened over and over
and over again well it's the remnants of
an ancient Society I mean we're dealing
with this ancient system that was
created long before we had anything
resembling our way of communicating that
we have now
[Applause]